chapter 4.
what is I doing what is I doing
I like because because right it's like
okay this is I I'm here
I exist okay then what the hell am I
even doing here like what do I do now
now that I know what I'm I okay now what
basically
yes and yeah and we talked about this
earlier it really feels like the word
play
and characters in play can be a powerful
way of seeing what is happening yes yes
and so
then we wonder like is I then playing
with choice
so eyes playing with these characters
with these identities
choosing character identities and and
making decisions because again we ask
the question what is I doing all right
what are you doing what are you doing
yeah and that's your answer are you
sitting here listening to us are you
kind of walking around your kitchen
making food while you're listening
that's what I is doing and so I think
that's important because it goes from
what is John doing to what is I doing
yeah and and it gives you a more
Foundation a deeper Foundation as to who
you actually are because now you're
starting to implement it in your daily
life yes start to say okay what is I
doing opposed to what is John doing and
it to me it makes me seem bigger I I
feel more vast
you know like all right there's a task
for I to do I feel like if eyes doing
something it better be important like
what am I doing like I'm a part of this
I'm sharing this eye with everybody else
so what choices am I making
you know you are the one that's making
all the choices that forms the life that
you're living yes yeah yes so let's say
that some of the key words are
play character and choice so then
what we're hinting at is
what are you doing in the sense of how
are you choosing or what are you
choosing when you're waking up every day
and let's say you're coming from the
knowledge or maybe just the label if
you're coming from just the label your
choice patterns will be different than
if you're coming from I knowing itself
and being the label at the same time and
so your choice patterns will be
different to move differently they'll
move you'll move differently throughout
and when you look at quote other people
that you'll feel the eye behind them the
label and so your choice pattern will be
different when you engage with them
you'll have more of a tendency towards
love and unity and that kind of stuff
and less of a tendency towards that's a
separate person that I can take
advantage of and extract things from
what not that resonance so so you're
going to have different Choice patterns
and so one one way to sort of you could
say create more will or create more
sovereignty is to like question your
choice patterns and to let's say
create more of a shift into what you
actually desire what you actually will
like what at this a great question like
what's in your North Star position your
entire day will morph towards that and
it might be something as simple as right
now my little North Stars to get some
food okay yeah yeah I was I was going to
say something what that means yeah like
a simple one versus something that might
be a little bit more of a grand goal
Grand goal yeah so the same goal might
be achieving a project or some sort of a
company yes goal of that sort or having
a family yes yeah yeah and then and so
day to day what choices am I making
that's going towards this North Star or
this goal yes and like you said like we
said The Power of Choice there's so much
power
I would almost say that
I mean maybe there's many reasons as to
why we're here but a big reason is to
make choices and I feel like doesn't
that sound so simple yes are you scared
to make some choices
yes and one of the most important
choices is
to forget yeah remember which we'll talk
about in more in more detail yeah and it
to in a sense liberate yourself more
from the conditioned habits and patterns
of being just the label and as you kind
of question your patterns and your
habits you can feel like an increase in
choice
and an increase in
like a differentiation it'll feel
different where you come from when you
have the knowledge of I and the label at
the same time yes
and then that power for Choice how
you'll like direct your attention then
is going to feel I don't even know like
who was I before yeah knowing this yeah
and that was one of the questions that
you asked in the documentary that's
coming up which is really interesting
yeah I just kind of want to know I
wanted to know who were the people that
we were talking to prior to them
basically expanding their minds before
accepting well a lot of them accepting
you know that their eye and that there's
more to them than just their namesake
what were you like before that and a lot
of them deep size like I don't even want
to talk about that but it's okay because
we all have that well everyone that's
crossing over into eyes like there was a
you before you decided to be I it most
likely was your name and uh we were lost
you know just unaware not knowing what
decisions we're making or the impact
that they'll have and again now that you
know that you're I and you have this
powerful choice you can Choose Wisely
hmm beautiful that's it